[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub
ja herzlich willkommen zum Presseclub
schön dass Sie da sind das war ein
beunruhigender Mittwochmorgen für viele
Menschen die Meldung direkt nach dem
Aufwachen groß Razzia im Reichsbürger
Milieu eine der größten Anti
terror-einsätze in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik es gab Festnahmen Waffen
wurden sichergestellt und es ging um
einen geplanten Staatsstreich Pläne die
die Sicherheitsbehörden an diesem Morgen
dann beendeten
Zugriff gegen die reichsbürgerszene die
größte deutsche Terror Razzia seit
Jahren mehr als 50 Beschuldigte im
Visier sie wollten wohl dem Bundestag
stürmen und trainierten mit Waffen
militante Reichsbürger verbindet der
Hass auf die Demokratie auf unseren
Staat und auf Menschen die für unser
Gemeinwesen eintreten die Wachsamkeit
der Behörden scheint groß aber die
Bedrohung von rechts auch die Vorwürfe
Bildung einer terroristischen
Vereinigung Umsturz Vorbereitungen
Waffen besitzt eine radikale
Splittergruppe mit Verbindungen in die
Mitte der Gesellschaft im Grunde nach
ist allen gemeinsam dass sie die
Existenz der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
leugnen dass sie das Grundgesetz für
nicht verbindlich betrachten und die
meisten Gruppierungen meinen dass das
Kaiserreich weiter fort besteht und das
daran wieder angeknüpft werden muss
bereits 2020 hatten afdler aggressiven
corona-demonstranten Zugang zum
Bundestag verschafft und jetzt auch die
frühere afd-abgeordnete und Richterin
Malser Winkelmann wurde verhaftet die
rechte Szene ist seit der corona-krise
in Bewegung und speist sich aus
Verschwörungstheoretikern aller Art wie
gefährlich ist das
der Razzia bei den reichsbürgern wie
gefährdet ist die Demokratie das ist
unser Thema heute hier im Presseclub ich
freue mich auf unsere Runde und sage
herzlich willkommen Holger stark er ist
stellvertretender Chefredakteur und
Ressortleiter investigativer Recherche
und Daten bei der Zeit außerdem in der
Runde möchte ich begrüßen Reinhard
Müller leitender Redakteur und
Ressortleiter von Zeit gestehen und
Staat und recht bei der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung ich begrüße
Katharina nocun Publizistin Bloggerin
und podcasterin in der Runde und
außerdem herzlich willkommen Katja
Riedel Reporterin bei WDR investigativ
und Teil des rechercheverbundes WDR und
Süddeutsche Zeitung wir wollen
diskutieren mit Ihnen beginnen über das
was wir gerade ja schon gehört haben
diese Dimensionen die es da am Mittwoch
Morgen gab rund 3000 Polizisten im
Einsatz die Festnahmen Waffen die
sichergestellt worden ist dieser Begriff
Staatsstreich aus ihrer Sicht wie
gefährlich war das Ganze
die Gefahr liegt glaube ich nicht so
sehr darin dass da morgen einen
Staatsstreich geschehen wäre das der
Reichstag gestimmt worden wäre und wir
dann wirklich die Abschaffung der
Demokratie erlebt hätten damit wäre die
Polizei schon ganz gut klar gekommen die
war ja ganz offensichtlich seit vielen
Monaten an dieser Gruppe schon dran was
mich wirklich beunruhigt ist diese
Mischung die wir da sehen das ist weit
über das klassische rechtsextreme
Spektrum hinaus da sind Elemente der
querdenkerszene mit dabei da ist eine
verschwörungstheoretische Bewegung die
von dem jüdischen Finanzkapital im
Hintergrund redet was angeblich
gestritten sieht und da ist eine AFD die
mittlerweile fast eine Lupen rein
rechtsextreme Partei geworden ist und in
dieser in diesem Gebäu was in diesem
giftigen Gebäu was dazu zusammengekommen
ist da ist eine Sprengkraft entstanden
die bis ins bürgerliche Milieu
reinreicht wir haben diesen bizarren
Prinzen gesehen wir haben die
Abgeordnete gesehen da sind aber auch
Piloten dabei ähm Ärzte Rechtsanwälte
ein Star Kochen ähnliches und das ist
eine Mischung die wir so eine
Vergangenheit nicht hatten eine neue
Mischung auch ein neues gefährdungslevel
Herr Müller kann man das so sagen
zunächst einmal die Demokratie
funktioniert der Rechtsstaat ist nicht
in Gefahr aber man sieht natürlich auch
dass in der Tages ins bürgerliche Lager
reingeht ich glaube aber muss auch
bedenken 3000 Polizisten haben im Namen
des Rechtsstaats gehandelt gestern hat
ein sek eine Mutter und ein Kind befreit
fast alle Beamten Arbeiten im Namen des
Rechtsstaats deswegen kann es auch
keinen Generalverdacht geben aber es ist
eine neue Qualität natürlich wenn von
einem sek Beamten aktiv bis zu einer
aktiven Richterin sich hier Staatsdiener
zusammenfinden ich glaube auch das wäre
vom Personal her da brauchen sie
irgendwo eine Schlüsselpersonal
Charismatiker wer das keine Gefahr
gewesen geworden ist es auch nicht aber
man muss sich Gedanken machen wie man
dieses Potenzial dass da insbesondere
seit der corona-krise die ja noch alles
noch mal aufgewirbelt hat und teilweise
auch berechtigte Fragen gestellt hat
teilweise auch abgedreht ist wie man
dieses Potenzial bändigen und zähmen im
Auge behalten kann ich glaube aber auch
im Staatsdienst gibt es keinen Anlass
für Aktionismus das sind eben doch
Einzelfälle man muss bloß überlegen wie
man diese Einzelfälle rausfilter gleich
in der Runde noch drauf kommen wenn wir
mal ein bisschen den Blick dann in die
Zukunft richten Frau Riedel wir haben es
gerade schon gehört ein Prinz dabei ein
Koch auch jetzt so in Reaktion auf diese
Razzia hat man ach so eine Rentnertruppe
Reichsbürger verwirrt wie weit daneben
liegt man mit dieser Einschätzung wenn
man das so abtut also man muss ja sagen
dass sich Leute die das professionell
machen auch schon viele Jahre lang seit
vielen Monaten diese Gruppierung
angeschaut haben und das auch in
Ermittlungsrichter zu der Einschätzung
gekommen ist das gegen 25 dieser
Personen Haftbefehl verhängt werden
sollte diese Menschen sind zu der
Erkenntnis gekommen dass es sich um eine
gefährliche terroristische Vereinigung
handelt und dass diese Personen
Mitglieder darin sind und dass wir nicht
beantwortet die Frage ob wir jetzt
sofort zu früh die Frage stellen sollten
ob das dann wirklich gefährlich war ja
das war gefährlich aus vielen Gründen
nicht wie Holger stark schon gesagt hat
weil da morgen vielleicht der Reichstag
gestürmt worden wäre sondern weil es
einfach eine Gruppe ist die Anfang zu
Waffen hatte Zugang zu Geld hatte die
jeglichen Glauben an diesen Staat
verloren hat und damit reden wir auch
nicht von Einzelfällen wie Herr Müller
gerade eben gemacht hat sondern meines
Erachtens von dem breiten Potenzial das
bereit ist so ein Weg zu gehen sich so
eine Gruppierung anzuschließen da würde
ich gleich gern ganz kurz noch bei ihnen
nachhaken Vorrede weil sie die Waffen
auch gerade angesprochen haben gibt eine
große Frage Runde schon auch bei Twitter
zu diesem Thema wissen sie etwas weil
sie waren auch im Recherche-Team dabei
welche Waffen da gefunden wurden also
nach unseren Erkenntnissen wurden sowohl
Waffen als auch Munition an etwa 50 der
130 durchsuchten Orte an diesem Tag
gefunden und es waren zu großen Teil
legale Waffen aber auch mit einer
legalen Waffe ist man in der Lage
jemanden zu töten vor allem auch wenn
man damit umgehen kann und auch über
militärische Ausbildung verfügt
wenn wir uns diese Gruppe anschauen wir
haben ja gerade schon gehört wer da
alles so dazu gehört wie gefährlich
bewerten Sie diese Situation die wir da
hatten am Mittwoch und die Person die
dazugehören
also man muss einfach sagen dass die
reichsbürgerszene schon immer ein großes
Gefahrenpotenzial war und es gab ja
schon einen Polizistenmord das vergessen
viele gerne also 2016 gab es den Versuch
bei einem Reichsbürger die Waffen
abzunehmen und da hat dieser sich eben
mit eben diesen Waffen gewehrt mehrere
Polizeibeamte wurden verletzt und einer
ist eben seinen Verletzungen erlegen es
gab in den letzten Jahren immer wieder
Funde von Waffen auch vielen Waffen mit
vielen Munition in diesem Milieu und man
muss sagen dass wir da eben Teile der
Szene haben die offen gewaltbereit
auftreten das sehen wir auch auf
telegram im übrigen und in den letzten
zwei drei Jahren hat man gesehen dass
sich auch verschiedene
verschwörungsideologisches Szenen
annähern ja also beispielsweise
Reichsbürger in Ideologie und kyuanon
Ideologie das heißt diese Leute die
glauben Trump wäre so eine Art Heiland
und die auch ja beispielsweise diesen
Putschversuch in den USA also die
Stürmung des Kapitels begrüßt haben eben
auch in den USA hat qanon da eine Rolle
gespielt muss man sagen das hat sich auf
telegram verbunden zu einer neuen sehr
unsinnigen Melange wo Leute auch sehr
offen zu Gewalt aufgerufen haben es
wurden auch immer wieder Aufrufe
veröffentlichten entsprechenden
Gruppierungen dass man Listen erstellen
müsse von Journalisten von
PolitikerInnen Politikern und dass diese
dann abgeholt werden dass diese
abgeurteilt werden das heißt die
Gewaltfantasien die haben wir online wie
offline seit vielen vielen Monaten
gesehen im übrigen auch auf Bühnen von
querdenken und Co es gab übrigens auch
bei den Polizisten dort einen Polizisten
der auch Informationen weitergegeben hat
also aus dem Staatsdienst aber trotzdem
muss man natürlich sagen nicht nur
Einzelfälle ist stimmt es ist eine neue
Qualität aber wenn ich das in die
gesamte Relation der beamtensätze die
treu und rechtsstaatlich konform ist
trotzdem eine überschaubare Größe auch
bei der Bundesanwaltschaft für das Jahr
zu Recht als touristische Vereinigung
verfolgt hoch Fahrrad wird geprüft das
auch nicht allzu häufig aber ich glaube
trotzdem Rechtsstaat war jetzt in der
Form nicht in Gefahr jetzt muss man aber
sagen Herr Müller werden wir uns mal auf
die aktuellen Zahlen
konzentrieren Frau Faser hatte jetzt
23.000 noch mal neu genannt Menschen die
dem Reichsbürger Milieu zugerechnet
werden deswegen Herr stark vielleicht an
Sie die Frage was was sind das für Leute
sind da auch mehr dazu jetzt gekommen
die ja vielleicht was ganz anderen
Bereichen in anderen Bereichen unterwegs
waren das sind Menschen die im
Wesentlichen eines eint und das ist ähm
die Verachtung für die liberale
Demokratie die der Meinung sind
Deutschland in den in dieser Form wie
wir es jetzt haben seit 1945 in der
nachkriegsform existiert eigentlich gar
nicht das ist doch hier eigentlich nur
eine Firma eine Art GmbH die Alliierten
haben Deutschland nie in die
Souveränität entlassen und die zurück
wollen ins Kaiserreich in die Grenzen
des Deutschen Reiches von 1871
verschiedene Spielformen und die in der
Konsequenz natürlich jeden staatlichen
Autoritäten die Legitimität absprechen
und das macht es so brandgefährlich die
sagen die Polizei ist überhaupt nicht
autorisiert hier was zu tun die Gerichte
die können mich anschreiben aber höre
ich gar nicht drauf und wenn wir 23.000
Leute haben die im Prinzip sagen jede
Institution hier hat mir überhaupt gar
nichts mehr zu sagen die eine große
Affinität zu Waffen haben dann haben wir
einen Potenzial was im Prinzip bereits
weiterzugehen und der Vergleich mit
Amerika ist nicht so ganz weit hergeholt
da haben wir gesehen wie beim Sturm auf
das Kapitol am 6 Januar wenn da so eine
kritische Masse zusammen kommt welche
grundsätzliche Sprengkraft das annehmen
kann und deswegen ist auch der Reichstag
als Ziel glaube ich nicht so ganz
zufällig weil er eben das Herz der
Demokratie darstellt und genau dahin
sollte diese Angriff gehen Frau Riedel
ist das zu weit gegriffen wenn man das
vielleicht mit der Situation in den USA
vergleicht das ähnliche Strukturen in
Deutschland entstehen könnten ähnliche
Aktion ist das eine Nummer zu groß oder
sagen Sie doch doch das ist auch bei uns
in Deutschland so möglich ich teile das
ähm vor allem auch wenn man sich
anschaut das ist ja eine Partei in
Deutschland gibt wo es zahlreiche
Akteure gibt die diese Inhalte auch
Teilen ne also
die AFD hat ja in den zehn Jahren knapp
zehn Jahren die sie jetzt existiert eine
gewaltige Entwicklung durchgemacht die
ist von einer eurokritikerpartei hin zu
einer rechtsextremen Partei in weiten
Teilen hat sie sich entwickelt sie wird
als Verdachtsfall auf Rechtsextremismus
davon fassungsverfassungsschutz
behandelt
und es gibt sie hat einen gewaltigen
Siegeszug durch die Parlamente natürlich
auch hingelegt und das dabei hat sie
gelernt zu nutzen was funktioniert was
taugt um ihre Wähler ihre
Wählerpotenzial zu generieren 15 Prozent
deutschlandweit sind gerade bereit die
AFD zu wählen aktuell Deutschland genau
und diese Menschen scheint auch nicht zu
stören dass da am Rednerpult im
Bundestag
Verschwörungstheorien verbreitet werden
vom angeblichen great gesät ähm das ist
auch alles ein Versatzstück dass diesen
Staat und dessen Legitimität in Frage
stellt und sie ja sie nutzt es einfach
sie nutzt auch Versatzstücke aus
Reichsbürger in Ideologie oder indem sie
zum Beispiel sagt auch auch Abgeordnete
sein nur systemvarionetten etc solche
Äußerungen findet man einfach zu Haupt
bevor wir Frau Riedel da jetzt ja zu
tief in die AFD da wollen wir uns gleich
auch noch mal darauf konzentrieren
wollte ich bei Frau Nuckel noch mal kurz
nachfragen sie haben das gerade schon so
angedeutet wir sprechen auch gerade über
die Strukturen wie organisieren sich
jetzt in diesem Fall auch die
Reichsbürger was stellen sie da fest wie
wie ist da gerade vor allem auch im Netz
die Kommunikation ja also man muss sagen
dass diese Zahl 23.000 mit großer
Vorsicht zu genießen ist weil sie sagen
deutlich mehr also es gibt eine viel
viel größeren Resonanzraum gerade online
für reichsbürgerideologie also das sieht
man allein daran dass es mehrere
Accounts gibt mit mehr als 100.000
Lesern deutlich mehr als 100.000
lesenden wo Reichsbürger Ideologie immer
wieder verbreitet wird auch in lokalen
verschwörungsideologischen Telegramm
Gruppen wird immer werden immer mal
wieder Andeutungen gemacht oder da links
zu Lupen rein reichen Organisation
verschickt und man muss auch sagen dass
wir in den letzten Jahren immer wieder
auch in rechtsextremen Milieus auch sage
ich mal in einem Resonanzraum in dem die
AFD durchaus auch nach Wählerinnen und
Wählern fischt dass wir da immer wieder
Andeutungen hören ja also beispielsweise
Deutschland hätte niemals einen
Friedensvertrag abgeschlossen
Deutschland wäre ein besetztes Land so
etwas hört man eben auch auf
Veranstaltungen auf den afd-politiker
Reden halten und von daher muss man
sagen das sind deutlich weit mehr
Menschen die eben offen für diese
Ideologien sind und man kann sich
natürlich fragen warum rutschen Menschen
in diese Milieus ab und da muss man
einfach auch sagen man darf nicht
vergessen dass Antisemitismus viel
weiter in der Gesellschaft verbreitet
ist als der ein oder andere das
vielleicht hoffen oder meinen würde das
heißt das stört sowas das dockt eben an
existierende Vorurteile an Rassismus an
Antisemitismus in der breiten
Bevölkerung an unsere erklärt sich eben
auch warum in dieser Gruppe wir Personen
finden wo sich viele sagen naja also da
hätte ich jetzt nicht vermutet dass der
beinahe rechtsextremen Terrorgruppe
mitmacht das ist ein Phänomen das sehen
wir eben ganz stark in der
verschwörungsideologischen Szene das
geht leider Gottes quer durch die
Bevölkerung
von Allensbach aus letztem Jahr wo 30
Prozent der Deutschen gesagt haben wir
leben in einer Scheindemokratie also 30
Prozent geht weit über die AFD
Wählerschaft hinaus trotzdem muss man
natürlich die falsche beunruhigen finde
ich auch während der corona-krise gab es
natürlich massive Grundrechtseingriffe
die sind in der Form noch nie gab
lockdowns maskenpflicht Diskussion über
die Impfpflicht die in allen Kreisen ist
übrigens nicht nur rechts links das war
eine bunte Mischung am Anfang so
besonders da Skepsis geführt hat die man
aber ernsthaft dann länger nicht haben
konnte aber ich glaube die Frage ist
trotzdem wenn wir über bürgerliche
Kreise sprechen und die Umsturzgefahr
ist diese
Demokratie Skepsis Staats Skepsis ist
schlägt das auch um in Radikalisierung
und da gibt es auch die Feststellung
dass sich das zum Beispiel
parteipolitisch jetzt gar nicht so
radikalisiert hat wie in anderen Ländern
im Osten ist es ein bisschen andere
Spiel in der Tat aber da hat jetzt zum
Beispiel ja die AFD nicht massiv
gewonnen sie ist erstmal durch die
flüchtlingskrise seinerzeit stark
geworden hat aber durch die corona-krise
jetzt nicht massiv geworden aber also
das heißt dieser Befund Scheindemokratie
ist beängstigend also der geht eben auch
über Reichsbürger wie tief in die
bürgerliche Lage anscheinend hinein oder
alle Schichten was das jetzt heißt würde
man jetzt ein Umschluss befürworten das
ist die spannende Frage möchte an der
Stelle noch mal den Hinweis geben dass
sie natürlich auch sehr gerne
mitdiskutieren können in unseren
sozialen Netzwerken auf unseren Kanälen
und auch gerne Ihre Meinung und Fragen
hier zum Presse loswerden können aber
Herr stark wenn Sie das jetzt gerade
hören
Herr Müller relativiert das ja so ein
bisschen ordnet ist ein bisschen
genau da haben wir mit meinen saß schon
davon genommen hat es eingeordnet wie er
die AFD da in der Rolle sieht wenn sie
hören es gibt eine extra AFD
Bundestagsabgeordnete die da jetzt auch
zu den Festgenommenen gehört wie
gefährlich sehen sie bewerten Sie die
Situation wenn sowas ins Parlament
reinführt wenn sie nicht vor vier Wochen
gefragt hätten oder vor acht Wochen ob
ich mir vorstellen kann dass eine
afd-abgeordnete AD die Richterin ist die
im Bundes-
[Musik]
was was in meiner Fantasie jedenfalls
nicht vorkommt warum nicht warum hätten
sie das noch anders eingeordnet weil ich
gedacht hätte dass die AFD eine Partei
ist doch versucht den Weg durch die
Parlamente zu gehen die versucht sich in
Ostdeutschland insbesondere als
Volkspartei zu etablieren 25% in Sachsen
und anderswo da ist sie potenziell die
stärkste Partei das alleine macht mir
Sorge genug die aber immer doch so ein
kleiner restabgrenzung zu dem ganz ganz
rechten Rand und vor allem auch den
militanten rechten Rand behält es sei im
Übrigen jetzt nicht nur die AFD am
Bundestagsabgeordnete die wir
festgenommen gesehen haben sondern es
gab noch ein ehemaligen
Landrat der früher für die AFD ähm im
Erzgebirge aktiver da gibt es
offenkundig schon so eine gewisse
Affinität es gibt jedenfalls ein
fehlendes abgrenzungsbewusstsein die AFD
hat sich so zwei drei Sätze abbringen
lassen dass sie sich davon distanziert
das war höchstens halbherzig und mir
macht diese wirklich strukturelle
Verankerung der AFD als Volkspartei in
Ostdeutschland extreme Sorge natürlich
hat hat Herr Müller recht dass wir nicht
von einem Umsturz stehen natürlich ist
es so dass der heiße Herbst der von der
AFD ausgerufen worden ist in diesem
Herbst einfach ausgefallen ist die
überwiegende Mehrzahl der Menschen in
diesem Land ist demokratisch die
Demokratie stabil und trotzdem haben wir
einen so starken rechten Rand
mittlerweile wo so viel zusammen kommt
dass ich mir darüber große Sorgen mache
und die berechtigte Frage die sich da
anschließen muss ist ja wie kommt das
eigentlich wenn wir sehen die AFD immer
wieder in der Nähe zum Rechtsextremismus
trotzdem eben in Ostdeutschland den noch
höheren Zuspruch aber sie haben schon
angesprochen aktuell bei 15% stabil bei
15% in der Sonntagsfrage ist das nicht
abschreckend für Wähler
erstaunlicherweise nicht ich würde sagen
die AFD hat ein recht stabiles
wähler:innenpotenzial von rund 9 bis 10
Prozent die 5%, die wir jetzt mehr sehen
sind ja der Ukraine Krise und in den
Energiekrise geschuldet die AFD kann
Krise das hat sie damals schon 2015/16
gezeigt da hat sie sich damals auf die
Migrationsfrage draufgelegt und ließ
sich in Höhenflüge tragen jetzt legt sie
sich auf diese ja auch staatskapsis die
die AFD dort transportiert die AFD
bietet ja keine Lösung an sondern sie
nimmt sich ein Problem und ähm ja sie
will das in allen Formen aus und damit
bietet sie dann ja ein einfaches
Integrationspotenzial
aber die anderen Parteien müssen eben
auch die Probleme adressieren die zum
Aufstieg der haben sie da haben sie
natürlich durchaus recht ich würde auch
andere Ansprache wäre wäre nötig ja
genau also die Leute die Sorgen die
Leute ernst nehmen und die gibt es eben
auch beim Themen wie Kriminalität Asyl
Einwanderung Staatsangehörigkeit das
nicht alles als rechtsradikal abtun
sondern eben versuchen
in der Ordnung die wir sind sozusagen
die die Dinge anzusprechen und zu regeln
und bei der flüchtlingskrise glaube ich
war schon ein Problem die AFD war ja vor
eine anti-europartei aus Professoren die
hatte auch schon rechtsradikale
Tendenzen in der Mitgliederschaft aber
sie ist ja nicht so gestartet sie war
keineswegs verfassungsfeindlich hat sich
dann gewandelt im Zuge der
flüchtlingskrise da kann man natürlich
schon die Frage stellen haben wieder
alles richtig macht die Regierung alles
richtig gemacht in der Form wie sie die
flüchtlingskrise eingetütet hat
und jetzt auch wieder bei Krone muss man
auch sagen es gab auch ein paar
Übertreibungen also wir haben den
schärfsten Lockdown der natürlich dazu
führt dass man eine gewisse auch
unterrichtswissenschaftlern Skepsis
entwickelt hat der sich die sich dann
auch verbreitet in radikalen Kreise
sagen die Regierung ist auch eine
Verantwortung die Parlament die
teilweise ausgefallen waren am Anfang
der Krise Probleme zu adressieren und
Extremismus auf diese Weise präventiv zu
bekämpfen also ich muss sagen ich habe
meine Probleme damit mit diesen oder
dieser Erzählung auch aus afd-sicht dass
man sich um die Probleme der Menschen
kümmern würde ich vermute sie haben das
nicht so gemeint alle Parteien haben die
Probleme aktuelle Umfragen was was sind
die Sorgen der Menschen ähm bietet die
AFD eine konstruktive Lösung das ist
meine Energie
ganz zentrales Thema wie viele Menschen
machen sich Sorgen um den zunehmenden
Rechtsruck in der Gesellschaft um die
zunehmende Gefahr von rechtsextremer
Gewalt und da muss ich sagen hat die AFD
nicht nur keine Antwort sondern schweigt
sehr laut mehr noch wir haben in den
letzten Tagen sehr stark gesehen dass
unterschiedliche Akteure aus der AFD
verschwörungserzählungen verbreiten zu
der zu der aktuellen Razzia da wird
beispielsweise behauptet dass sei eine
Inszenierung man müsste das gar nicht
ernst nehmen anstatt sich damit zu
beschäftigen dass eine ja ein Mitglied
der Partei dass eben im Schiedsgericht
auch darüber entschieden hat oder
vielleicht auch noch entscheidet ich
weiß nicht ob da mittlerweile überhaupt
Konsequenzen gezogen worden sind ob
jemand beispielsweise wegen
rechtsextremer Partei aus der
rechtsextremer Umtriebe aus der Partei
ausgeschlossen wird oder nicht dass so
jemand allein diesen Posten hatte das
sagt unglaublich viel über die Partei
aus und man muss ja auch sagen dass die
AFD in den letzten Jahren nicht nur ein
wenig gekuschelt hat mit der
rechtsextreme und
verschwörungsideologischen Szene es gab
Mitarbeitende bei unterschiedlichen
Abgeordneten die wirklich guten rein aus
der rechtsextremen Szene sind und auch
deshalb wahrscheinlich eingestellt
worden sind und wir hatten natürlich
auch diese Situation dass die AFD gleich
bessere Konferenzen im Bundestag
veranstaltet hat wo man sich Rechte und
verschwörungsideologische influencer
eingeladen hat das heißt aus Sicht der
AFD ist die Szene eine Art Hausmacht die
man auch aktiv bespielt was kann ich
einfach sagen
wo auf hat sie sich gesetzt und was
können wir alle tun um das zu verhindern
die Frage ist auch was was kann man
rechtlich tun was kann die Politik tun
es gibt jetzt verschiedene Forderungen
die natürlich in den vergangenen Tagen
aufgeploppt sind erst heute morgen
ceso landesgruppenchef Dobrindt hat
gesagt er könnte sich vorstellen eine
bundesweite Beobachtung der AFD Frau
Riedel würde das was bringen wer das
sinnvoll ist es überhaupt möglich also
jetzt haben wir die AFD jetzt erstmal
bundesweit als Verdachtsfall wir haben
sie noch nicht als erwiesen
rechtsextremistische Partei da hat auch
das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz
jetzt fünf Jahre Zeit sich mit
nachrichtendienstlichen Mitteln mit Frau
Leuten etc
noch mehr Kenntnisse über die interner
der AFD zu verschaffen und das ist ja
erstmal eigentlich auch
die Beobachtung ausreichend ich halte es
aber auch nicht für zielführend eine
Partei die in mehreren Bundesländern in
Ostdeutschland gerade zu mehrheitsfähig
ist in der Volkspartei wie Herr stark
eben gesagt hat zu verbieten weil damit
haben wir jetzt erstmal nichts gelöst
wir haben ja damit die Gedanken nicht
verboten wir haben die Milieus nicht
aufgelöst in denen diese Gedanken
geteilt werden wir haben die
telefongruppe telegram-gruppen nicht
aufgelöst in denen diese Inhalte geteilt
werden sondern ich glaube wir müssen
tatsächlich Lösungen finden wie man
zumindest einen Teil dieser Menschen
auch wieder zurück gewinnt für diesen
Staat ist das so verstanden
ich bin ohnehin nicht so ein Freund
davon dann ein bisschen zu
Verbotsforderungen zu gehen das kann nur
die ultimarat zu einem Rechtsstaat sein
dass der Verfassungsschutz da jetzt
hinschaut das ist in Ordnung um dann in
Ruhe zu schauen was man sieht das
Problem was ich sehe Herr Müller ist die
AFD hat vielleicht mal als Protestpartei
angefangen und dann hat sie sich aber
mindestens drei viermal gehäutet wir
haben die erste Generation gesehen und
während Luke die da rausgegangen ist das
waren die eure kritischen Professoren
wie sie immer genannt wurden dann haben
wir Petri gesehen die die Partei
verlassen hat wir haben zuletzt Jörg
Meuthen gesehen und immer hieß es sind
die moderaten die gehen uns
zurückgeblieben ist ein harter rechter
Kern und wir haben heute eine Partei die
auch im Besenstiel hätte hinstellen
können und immer noch von neun bis zehn
Prozent gewählt worden würde wer heute
die AFD wählt der weiß was er wählt der
hat es zu tun mit einer klar
rechtsradikal in Teilen auch
rechtsextremen Partei und das macht mir
Sorge dass wir offensichtlich zehn
Prozent zwölf Prozent der Bevölkerung
haben sie sich gar nicht scheut zu sagen
das ist ja eine rechtsradikale Partei
die wähle ich und die Frage ist und die
große Frage auf die bislang keine
Parteien eine vernünftige Antwort
gefunden hat wie adressiere ich dieses
Protest und problempotenzial wurde ganz
kurz bei Frau nuckeln gerne nachfragen
wenn wir gerade hören sie hätten auch
ein Besenstiel hinstellen können sind es
nur die Krisen wo Menschen sich
möglicherweise nach einfacheren
Antworten sehr Sehnen oder was glauben
Sie wo liegt das Potenzial das ist fast
egal ist mit welchen Themen man
aufschlägt also zu dieser Frage könnte
man natürlich eine ganze Sendung machen
das ist nicht so einfach zu beantworten
was man aber sagen muss ist das
zumindest stark radikalisierte Teil der
verschwörungsideologie
radikalisierten Wählerschaft
dass man da mittlerweile auch mit der
Realität immer weniger Berührungspunkte
hat das heißt es ist unabhängig davon ob
Lösungen für Krisen gefunden werden wie
diese Lösungen aussehen es wird auf
telegram oder in den entsprechenden Jahr
filterblasen kann man schon sagen der
Szene einfach immer sehr negativ
dargestellt Krisen werden teilweise auch
überspitzt dargestellt neu geschaffen
fast schon und von daher muss man sagen
man kommt da kaum noch von außen dran
und das ist natürlich auch gewollt weil
das ist ja auch irgendwo diese Strategie
Trump dass man von Fake News spricht
wenn man eben von kritischer
Medienberichterstattung spricht und
damit kann man sich sozusagen natürlich
auch ein kleines medienreich schaffen wo
man ja wo Kritik gegen einen selbst gar
nicht mehr wirklich vorkommt und wenn
sie denn doch mal wenn Anhängerschaft
damit konfrontiert wird kann man das
einfach ab tun nach ja das sind ja die
gesteuerten Medien von denen da oben und
das macht mir große Sorge also man muss
natürlich sagen es gibt einen großen
Unterschied zwischen der
Medienlandschaft in Deutschland und in
den USA also so einen großen Player wie
Fox News haben wir hier einfach nicht
und man darf auch nicht unterschätzen
dass es eben nicht immer nur social
Media ist sondern in den USA haben große
Rechte rechtspopulistische Akteure im ja
also sag mal Medien Imperien da auch
eine große Rolle gespielt und gerade im
Bezug auf verschwörungserzählung glaube
ich schon dass diese Melange Ebene große
Rolle spielt und das macht es eben auch
so schwierig von außen noch anzukommen
also faktenchecks interessieren einen
Teil der Wählerschaft einfach überhaupt
nicht mehr weil sie sagen ich glaube
nicht einmal mehr an Wissenschaft ich
würde gerne mal einen Schritt
weitergehen und noch mal in ein anderes
Feld unsere Gesellschaft gehen auch wenn
wir schauen wer unter den festgenommen
ist wir müssen mal über unsere
Sicherheitsbehörden sprechen
ehemalige Offiziere waren dabei auch
nach einem Polizist jetzt ist die Rede
von einem LKA-Beamten der zumindest als
Unterstützer gehandelt wird wie
besorgniserregend ist das Herr Müller
das ist schon besorgniserregend bei der
Richterschaft würde ich sagen das sind
immer wieder Fälle vorgekommen die auch
behandelt wurden Anführungsstrichen
teilweise auch öffentlichen Druck das
waren öffentlich geäußerte schlimme
Sachen zum Beispiel Jens Meyer in
Sachsen
Disziplinarverfahren vor dem
Dienstgericht lief ja auch gegen die
Berliner Richterin das kommt schon raus
man fragt sich natürlich wie kommt zu
jemand in die Justiz wie entwickelt sich
also ich hätte auch kein war Problem
damit eine Regel Anfrage zumindest bei
dem Bewerbern zu machen denn man
entscheidet sich ja für den öffentlichen
Dienst für ein ganz wichtiges Amt
unabhängig zu handeln und man ist auch
kaum zu entlassen nach der Probezeit
jedenfalls nicht denn ich keine Probleme
das machen ja manche Bundesländer auch
Anfrage beim Verfassungsschutz man muss
dann natürlich immer noch bewerten
Verfassungsschutz ist bei uns nicht Gott
gleich der kann auch keine Partei
verbieten man muss das Auswerten was
findet er raus aber ich finde sowas
darüber kann man nachdenken und selbst
beim radikalen Erlass der wurde
teilweise zwar mit Kanonen auf Spatzen
geschossen aber das Grundprinzip dass
ich da als Staatsdiener
mich dahinter stellen muss und für die
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
einzutreten das ist klar ich finde aber
noch weiter zu führen diese Frage die
jetzt etwas untechnisch Beweislast
Umkehr genannt wird es kann nicht sein
dass man jetzt sagen muss Beweise bitte
dass du kein Verfassungsfeind bist da
kommen wir gleich noch mal zu das kann
der Gesetzgeber sozusagen dieser blinde
Aktionismus dem Fall absolut nicht
angemessen ist und der auch glaube ich
gegen Fall zu einer Abwendung von
einigen Staatsdienern von diesem Stadt
führen könnte
der bundesinnenministerin väser der
jetzt wie sie es ja auch gerade schon
getan haben auch durchaus kritisch
betrachtet wird aber gerne noch mal ähm
damit wir sehr stark auch einfach mal so
eine Größenordnung haben das sagt sich
immer so ja die Verbindungen in Polizei
und Bundeswehr wovon reden wir denn da
überhaupt also damit wir einfach mal ein
Gefühl dafür bekommen wir reden von äh
zahlenmäßig relativ wenigen das ist aber
natürlich bei hunderttausenden von
Polizisten trotzdem keine Indikator wir
haben es gesehen in Frankfurt
beispielsweise wo es diverse chatgruppen
gehabt wo Witze gemacht wurden über
auschwitzt und über die Vergasung von
Juden das sind diese geschlossenen
geschlossenen Einheiten geschlossenen
Kommunikationsräume wo ganz schnell mit
so einem chorgeist dann was entsteht wo
ausländerfeindliche rassistische Witze
gerissen werden wo sich dann jemand
traut dem zu widersprechen und wo dann
so eine Stimmung und so eine Dynamik
entsteht wo es ganz schwer ist da wieder
rauszukommen bei der Polizei haben
relativ vielen Stellen gesehen bei der
Bundeswehr teilweise beim KSK ähm der
Eliteeinheit der Bundeswehr auch unter
den festgenommen jetzt sind mehrere
ehemalige kskala die mit zur
Gründungsgeneration der Karos kennt das
KSK zählten und ein aktiver noch wie
gesagt das sind einige wenige die aber
in bestimmten sehr geschlossenen
Einheiten eine bestimmte Klima eine
bestimmte Stimmung erzeugen können und
dann andere mitreißen ich glaube das ist
viel viel zu spät erkannt worden in den
letzten Jahren ist schon einiges
geschehen aber das ist ein super Tanker
der sich ganz langsam dreht weil es um
den Kulturwandel geht weil es um eine
Offenheit geht weil es auch um eine
Diversität in der Zusammensetzung wer
denn eigentlich in der deutschen Polizei
dient geht
ist es richtig dass da jetzt ein
bisschen was passiert das auch an dem
Dienstrecht an der ein oder anderen
Stelle was
geändert wird das war bislang so dass
Disziplinarrecht teilweise drei vier
Jahre gedauert hat so dass die Leute
doch im Dienst bleiben konnten ein
bisschen Entscheidung getroffen worden
ist das muss alles schneller gehen und
vor allem muss es diese Offenheit der
Vorgesetzten geben würde gerne noch mal
sagen man sieht ja auch ähm wenn man
sich die Biografien jetzt dieser
Mitglieder dieser mutmaßlichen
terroristischen Vereinigung anschaut das
ist auch Menschen sind die oft dann
Brüche hatten in ihrem Biografien die
auch vielleicht am Ende ihrer Dienstzeit
dann ähm ja mit Problemen da
ausgeschieden sind vielleicht muss man
auch was das Thema Prävention angeht da
stärker betreuen im Nachhinein und
stärker diese Leute auf dem Schirm haben
die ausgeschieden sind weil das waren ja
alles
ex-bundes Werler exkalskala
einige waren im aktiven Dienst aber die
Mehrheit war ja nicht mehr im aktiven
Dienst es gibt ja immer wieder diesen
darauf dass man diesen diesen Rechten
Terrorismus vielleicht nicht so bei den
Sicherheitsbehörden lange Zeit auf dem
Schirm hatte auch wenn sich das ändert
und ist das etwas was sie auch so
wahrnehmen in den Umfeldern wo sie quasi
merken wieder auch kommuniziert wird
also ich merke einfach auch zum Teil
Sorge große Sorge bei Menschen die sich
beruflich mit dem Thema
Rechtsextremismus beschäftigen weil klar
wenn man dann so etwas liest Rechte
chatgruppe bei Polizei mal fragt sich so
okay ist das aktuell oder ist das vom
letzten Jahr oder ist das das vom Jahr
davor ja es gibt mittlerweile so viele
Fälle wo man sagen muss das sorgt
natürlich für Unruhe weil das natürlich
Menschen sind die nicht nur Zugang zu
Waffen haben und eine Ausbildung sondern
die haben natürlich auch Zugang zu melde
Daten das heißt Sie können nachgucken wo
wohnt denn der Aktivist die Aktivistin
oder die Politikerin und von daher muss
man sagen dass sorgt natürlich nicht
unbedingt dafür dass Menschen Vertrauen
in Institutionen haben und ich finde das
ist ganz gefährlich in der Demokratie
und was vor allem
und zur Sorge gibt im Bezug auf die
aktuelle Situation ist ja wir haben
gelesen dass da Menschen waren die
teilweise über einen längeren Zeitraum
versucht haben unter Kolleginnen
Kollegen oder Ex-Kollegen Menschen zu
rekrutieren die Frage ist wie viele
haben das ihrem Vorgesetzten gemeldet
oder hat es überhaupt jemand seinem
Vorgesetzten gemeldet und da müssen wir
natürlich auch darüber sprechen was für
eine Kultur herrscht in
Sicherheitsbehörden und ich denke es
wäre fatal wenn wir eine Kultur hätten
in einzelnen Bereichen wo eben jemand
der rechtsextreme Umtriebe meldet als
Nestbeschmutzer angesehen schätzen sie
das ein Handy
sehen wir jetzt nur die Folge einer
zutreffenden Sensibilisierung für das
Thema vor 30 Jahren Bundeswehr überhaupt
kein Thema ein Polizeikräften und jetzt
wird das gemeldet wird aufmerksam
verfolgt man kann auch in schätz mal
reingucken es gibt früher gab es gar
keine Schätze in der Form ich glaube
aber in der Tat bei der solchen Gruppen
die KSK sek sek bestimmte
Polizeieinheiten ist es auch schwierig
also erstmal fühlen sich nur bestimmte
Leute angezogen womöglich und es ist
auch schwierig bei jedem Vorfall eine
Meldung zu erwarten weil die halt
teilweise auf Leben und Tod zueinander
stehen und sich zumindest nicht
verpfeifen wollen das heißt nicht dass
die alle jetzt mitgehen würden wenn
einer ich glaube das ist das gibt eine
bestimmte Kultur wo ebenfalls dass
man das als anscher und verpfeifen
überhaupt ich will nur daran erinnern
50 Jahre nach den FDP worden sagen
einige von denen die 40 Jahren Knast
sagen ich sage nicht mehr Schleier
erschossen hat man verpfeift sich nicht
mehr einer gesagt auch die haben ihre
Strafe abgerissen die wissen dass das
Verbrechen Mann verpfeift sich nicht nur
als Gegenbeispiel aus einem anderen Raum
auch nach 40 Jahren nicht und wir sagen
nicht wer konkret leider geschossen hat
und ich glaube das ist ein Punkt
jedenfalls im Hinterkopf haben muss aber
natürlich kann es nicht sein dass wenn
jemand jetzt fragt der macht mit beim
Putsch das ist nicht gemeldet wird das
kann nicht sein ich glaube
vertrauen muss dann möchte ja aber wie
gesagt es ist das darf das ist eine
andere Arbeitsweise als vielleicht in
der Redaktion und selbst da würde man
vielleicht nicht jeden Kollegen wegen
jeder Sache anschwärzen
sie das ähnlich ja ich finde vor allem
erstaunlich also bis jetzt weiß man ja
über die aktuelle über den aktuellen
fallschuhen das offenbar kein einziger
der so angesprochenen ist tatsächlich
gemeldet hat
das finde ich schon wirklich sehr sehr
sehr erschreckend und was ich jetzt im
Zuge auf mein Feld indem ich sehr viel
recherchiere nämlich die AFD feststelle
ist dass in Hintergrund gestrichen die
ich führe da dann doch die recht gute
Kontakte zu den Sicherheitsbehörden oft
zu bestehen scheinen habe ich den
Eindruck und auch in der
Bundestagsfraktion gibt es ja viele
Leute die mal in ihrem Vorleben Juristen
waren also Richter Staatsanwälte etc
also da gibt es ja überall noch
Verbindung auch in die ehemaligen
Milieus auch Polizisten sind da runter
manche gehen auch zurück obwohl sie
unglaubliche Sachen im Bundestag
geäußert haben gehen Sie dann zurück in
ihre in ihre Polizisten Tätigkeit dass
man alles nicht vergessen die Frage die
sich natürlich daraus ergibt und das
würde ich gerne mit Ihnen jetzt noch
besprechen ist der Blick in die Zukunft
ist ja gerade schon gehört es gibt
Vorschläge der bundesinnenministerin
Herr Müller
eine Gesetzesänderung die Beweislast
umzukehren wie sinnvoll sind diese
Vorschläge aus ihrer Sicht und gibt es
Alternativen wo sie sagen nee also das
wäre jetzt für mich der Punkt wo man
sagt so kriege ich Menschen die mit
unserer Demokratie nichts anfangen
können aus dem öffentlichen Dienst raus
oder vielleicht auch ja in dem Fall aus
einem richter-dienst heraus wie kann das
funktionieren zumindest kann es nicht
sein dass das Jahre dauert wenn ich ihn
wirklich ein erwiesenen rechtsradikalen
der sozusagen selbst im Richter Dienst
hätte ausländerfeindlich hetzt dass das
Jahre dauern soll oder lange dauern soll
weil ich auch vielleicht früheres nicht
berücksichtigen darf kann nicht sein
also schon normalen Arbeit Arbeitsrecht
ist ja oft schwer ein Arbeitnehmer der
nicht arbeitet auszuschmeißen im
öffentlichen Dienst gibt's sowieso viel
zu lange Kautelen aber ist natürlich
klar das ist beim Richteramt eine
besondere Unabhängigkeit darf
eine der Festgenommenen bis zum Schluss
aktive Richterin genau
geben Sie in Ansage den könnte man aber
finden und deren Maier auch gefunden das
sollte nicht das Problem sein aber
trotzdem ist natürlich richtig im
Hinterkopf zu behalten ich kann Richter
nicht aus politischen Gründen absetzen
jetzt mal ganz grundsätzlich sonst
könnte man auch bald sagen sagen
vielleicht auch einige ein Richter der
die klimakräger freispreicht weil er
sagt das immer rechtfertigen Notstand
zum Klimakrise den würden vielleicht
einige Landesregierung auch sofort
rausschmeißen weil sie sagen dass der
will auch eine andere Ordnung also das
muss man im Hinterkopf behalten
aber ich glaube bei der Geschwindigkeit
kann man das machen auch bei der
verfassungsschutzabfrage jedenfalls bei
Bewerbern warum soll die nicht volle
ausgeleuchtet werden kann sprich kein
Grund dagegen man muss auch nicht von
der Zustimmung abhängig machen wenn ich
in Staatsdienst will muss ich mich dem
unterwerfen aber wie gesagt dieses
stellt sich vor es gibt
korruptionsvertrag dann wird wieder
Kollege in einer Redaktion in einem
Sender gefragt jetzt sag bitte du bist
aber nicht koruckt und dann sogar
verbergen also das ist glaube ich der
falsche Weg weil wie gesagt ganz viele
Beamte machen treu ihren Dienst und die
würden dann sozusagen
Generalverdacht gestellt und das wäre
kontraproduktiv bin ich bei Reinhard
Müller
ich glaube was zwingt ist ist den
reichsbürgern die Waffen wegzunehmen wer
sagt dass er diesen Staat ablehnt und
zurück ins Kaiserreich will hat kein
Recht auf Waffe hat jetzt angekündigt
das Waffenrecht noch weiter zu verändern
und da frage ich mich ganz simpel warum
erst jetzt aber gut das muss zwingend
als nächstes kommen es liegt noch nicht
verabschiedetes Demokratie
förderungsgesetz da Förderung der
Zivilgesellschaft ist glaube ich ein
ganz entscheidender Punkt das sollte
dringend kommen und dann würde ich mir
auch wünschen dass wir mal ein paar
klare Sätze hören von Leuten wie
Hans-Georg Maaßen dem ehemaligen
verfassungsschutzschiff der sich ähm
höhnisch über die Razzia geäußert hat
wünschen ich würde mir die den Satz
wünschen ja klar wir können über
Konservatismus in diesem Land reden wir
können darüber reden was falsch läuft
aber es gibt eine Grenze die nicht zu
überschreiten ist und diese Grenze hat
diese Gruppe überschritten so kann es
nicht weitergehen hört auf damit diesen
Satz würde ich mir wünschen wenn wir
einen Uwe tel kamen hören den
Schriftsteller der gar nicht anerkennt
was ist Fakten gibt sondern erstmal sagt
woher wissen wir denn das ist da
wirklich so war dass es dieses diesen
Putschversuch gegeben hat wenn wir den
Roland Tichy von Tichys Einblick Lesen
der
veräppelt was da geschehen ist also wenn
wir an den rechten Rand des
konservativen Spektrums gehen und sehen
wie es eben keine klare Abgrenzung gibt
aber wir haben auch von Friedrich Merz
noch nichts dazu gehört auch von
Friedrich Merz würde ich mir wünschen
dass es einen klaren Satz dazu gibt das
kostet aus meiner Sicht nicht so
wahnsinnig viel und würde trotzdem ganz
klar machen wo die Grenze verläuft wo
einen demokratische Diskurs beginnt und
wo er auch endet und wo Umstürze solche
Dinge geschehen die dann wiederum
wirklich ein Fall für die
Sicherheitsbehörden sind wie kann man in
Zukunft meinungsblasen vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr aufbrechen dass man
verhindert dass Menschen sich eh immer
nur gegenseitig noch bestätigen in
sozialen Netzwerken aber auch vielleicht
einfach nur am Stammtisch wie kann man
daraus kommen
ja so ist es ganz schwierig an bestimmte
Leute oder Gruppen noch ranzukommen und
wir müssen uns einfach auch klar machen
dass es Reichsbürger Milieu auch nicht
in den letzten drei Jahren entstanden
ist sondern das war tatsächlich auch ein
Thema schon in den frühen 2000ern und
schon da gab es diese Überschneidungen
eben auch totalen Esoterik zu
verschwörungsglauben zur militanten
rechtsextremen Szene und rechtsextremen
Parteien eben auch und was mir ganz
wichtig ist ist vor allem dass wir in
Zukunft eben auch gesellschaftlich rote
Linien ziehen das heißt dass wenn
beispielsweise jemand auf eine
einschlägigen Bühne auftritt und
einschlägige Reichsbürger aber
verschwörungsideologische
umstürzlerische Thesen da verbreitet
dass der schnell aus dem Dienst entfernt
wird weil das hat eine große
strahlwirkung in der Szene solche Leute
werden gefeiert da wird teilweise intern
dann verbreitet ja eigentlich ist die
Polizei hinter uns oder die Bundeswehr
sowieso sofort eingreifen wenn wir nur
sozusagen den ersten Funken legen das
muss schnell gehen und es braucht vor
allem Aufklärung in Gesellschaft aber
auch in den Behörden dass Menschen
schnell erkennen hoch das ist
Reichsbürger Ideologie ja also wenn
jemand Sätze sagt wie weiß ich nicht die
anfangen mit BRD GmbH wenn jemand sagt
Deutschland hat eigentlich keine
Verfassung oder ist besetzt da müssen
bei mir die alarmleuchten aufgehen und
das ist in der medialen
Berichterstattung 2020 zu Beginn von
querdenken und Co an vielen Stellen
nicht passiert wir dürfen nicht
vergessen der ehemalige Pressesprecher
von Querdenken hat Verbindung zum
reichsbürgermilieu gehabt das ist lange
bekannt gewesen und auch der Gründer von
Querdenken hat sich mit dem bekanntesten
Reichsbürger Deutschlands getroffen also
was mir hier deutlich wird auf jeden
Fall eine Runde ist das dieses klare
ansprechen klare erkennen einen ein
Thema sein muss Frau die andere Sache
ist wie kommt man an Menschen noch dran
die möglicherweise ja die Fakten die
Diskussionsbasis auf der wir uns im
Regelfall befinden verlassen haben gibt
es da Gruppen die man einfach nicht mehr
erreicht
leider ist das so glaube ich aber ich
selber versuche es trotzdem ich versuche
das Gespräch weiterhin zu suchen und
kann das eigentlich auch nur jedem
empfehlen diese Dinge die von nukung
gerade genannt hat wenn man sowas hört
im persönlichen Umgang dass man es
einfach anspricht dass man aufklärt dass
man es einfach versucht obwohl es so
schwer ist die Menschen zu erreichen und
was ich auch sagen möchte ist ich
wünsche mir tatsächlich wie Herr stark
auch aus dem konservativen Milieu aber
auch aus dem liberalen Menü heraus eine
stärkere Zuwendung zu diesem Thema eine
stärkere Verantwortung diese Leute
zurückzuholen das kann also der der
konservative der aus seiner Partei sich
herausgefallen fühlt der lässt sich
nicht vom linken oder vom SPD
zurückholen sondern das kann nur das
konservative Milieu oder das liberale
Milieu schaffen wo wir zu wenn er mich
nicht gekommen sind sind auch die rechts
lieber teren die extrem Liberalen die
auch aus der Gesellschaft hier
rausgefallen sind die was würde ich mir
sehr wünschen reden
muss mit ihnen das reden also meine
fingern sich auf eine
bundesverfassungsrecht Entscheidungen
sagen das stimmt wir leben mit einer
staatsrechtlichen Kontinuität aber ist
natürlich völliger Blödsinn zeigt mir wo
das steht dass wir die
verfassungsrechtliche Ordnung nicht
anerkennen dürfen und das kann auch
hilfreich sein das kann auch in
einzelverhältnisreich sein das nehmen
wir mit an dieser Stelle danke ihnen
erstmal für diese Runde deine Presseclub
ist an dieser Stelle zu Ende ist folgt
jetzt gleich das europamagazin im ersten
unter anderem mit dem Thema Artenschutz
und es geht weiter bei Phoenix und im
Radio bei WDR 5 mit dem Presseclub
nachgefragt danke für Ihr Interesse für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit Danke schön an die
Runde einen schönen dritten
Adventssonntag noch
ja herzlich willkommen zurück zum
Presseclub nachgefragt für nix und im
Radio bei WDR 5 Razzia bei den
reichsbürgern wie gefährdet ist die
Demokratie dass es unser Thema heute
dass wir in der Runde diskutieren aber
das wollen wir natürlich gerne mit ihrer
Meinung auch machen mit ihren Fragen
dazu und ich würde sagen wir fangen
direkt mal an in Berlin in der
Hauptstadt da ist Frank Knut hallo Herr
Knuth willkommen in der Runde ja schönen
guten Tag danke dass du gestellt wurde
ich habe ein folgendes ein Problem ich
glaube dass man mit diesem Maßnahmen nur
die Symptome bekämpft wie bei einer
Krankheit und nicht die Ursache wenn man
sieht dass die eine spitzes Eisbergs
darstellt man vermutet noch so viel mehr
sind da muss man doch versuchen diese
Truppen die da drunter ist zu erreichen
und das glaube ich viel von der Politik
aber auch von Emilien da falsch
rangegangen wird als Beispiel wir hatten
in Leipzig oder haben immer noch diese
montags Prozess oder diese Umläufe
Protesten die sind das Volk dass man da
hingeht und sagt das ist falsch ihr
müsst sagen auch wir sind das Volk ihr
habt eine Minderheit ihr seid das wir
müssen auf euch hören wie ihr das zu
reichen und muss versuchen so die Hand
dienen zu bieten ich vergleiche das mal
als ich jung war in den 60er Jahren kam
die 68 auf danach in den siebter als ich
Jugendlicher war war die RAF gerundet
worden und genau da gab es ja auch
Politiker oder bestimmte Stellen die
gesagt haben die konnten die abdriften
wie können wir die zurückholen oder ein
Teil davon in die Hand reichen und das
vermisse ich zurzeit so ein bisschen und
ich glaube das muss es sein um die Sache
wieder in Not zu kriegen weil sonst hat
man nur Druck gegen Druck und das klappt
nicht nur danke Ihnen für Ihre Meinung
vielleicht eine Antwort darauf wie kann
man da drauf zu gehen kann ich gar nicht
so wahnsinnig viel hinzufügen weil er
weil er schlecht Recht hat was wir bei
der Zeit zum Beispiel probiert haben ist
Deutschland spricht wir haben nach einem
Algorithmus Leute ausgesucht die maximal
gegensetzliche Position zueinander
hatten und haben sie zum Dialog
zusammengebracht
und anderen Medien zusammen weil wir das
Gefühl hatten wir müssen extreme Lager
extreme konträre Position überhaupt
wieder ins Gespräch bringen Maßnahmen
aus diesen filterbubbles über die so
viel geredet worden ist die die zu
durchbrechen aber das ist natürlich ein
mühseliger Prozess das kann man nicht
messen in schnellen Erfolgen ja der
Befund ist richtig ja wir müssen mehr
miteinander reden hilft es schnell nein
tut es nicht okay und eine schnelle
Lösung ist ja wahrscheinlich das was wir
eigentlich anstreben sollten ich würde
gerne Herrn Hofmann mit dazu nehmen
Bernau am Chiemsee herr Hofmann schönen
guten Tag ja hallo also ich habe Angst
zu merken dass die rechtsstaatlichen
Prinzipien eingehalten eingehalten
werden müssen das heißt es gilt eine
Unschuldsvermutung wir sind hier in
keiner Bananenrepublik
es ist jeder nur dann schuldig wenn
Zweifelsfall seine Schuld nachgewiesen
wird und ich glaube wir sollten es den
Behörden überlassen die das machen noch
eine kleine Anmerkung zu dieser
Richterin dieser Mahlzeit Winkelmann der
hat ja auch wieder Einstellung vorm
Verwaltungsgericht geklagt und ist dann
wieder als Richterin eingestellt worden
ja das heißt sie hat sich nach den
Rechtsstaat Prinzipien gehalten und ist
dann wieder als Richterin eingesetzt
worden und der zweite Punkt warum man
den Tisch immer fertig macht der die
demokratischen Prinzipien in der
Berliner Wahl die keiner dort ernst
genommen hat
drauf gedrungen hat und zu einer
Wiederholung der Wahl die wahrscheinlich
zur Wiederholung der größten Teil des
wahlablauf geführt haben
Herr Hoffmann danke Ihnen für Ihre
Anmerkung wer mag was dazu sagen Herr
Müller ganz klar aber wenn der
Generalbundesanwalt ein dringenden
Tatverdacht für Mitgliedschaft und
regelsführerschaft in der
terroristischen Vereinigung sieht da
können Sie davon ausgehen da ist der
Thomas dran und es wurde auch immer
berichtet mutmaßlich manchmal fällt das
auch weg weil es nicht anders geht im
Zuge der Berichterstattung aber es wird
immer darauf gepocht dass das natürlich
noch keinen rechtskräftiges Urteil ist
aber ich glaube trotzdem muss man
darüber reden weil es eben sehr
schwerwiegend ist in mehrere
Bundesländern wurde alles angesprochen
mit Waffen also ich glaube diese
grundfakten die diesen dringenden
Tatverdacht bewegen und das ist eben
auch noch nicht so häufig vorgekommen in
dem Umfang
zeigen dass wir die umstellstverbote
hochhalten aber das ist auch schon
schwerwiegende Gründe gibt zu glauben
dass da was dran ist
wir haben aus dieser Lohn einer Klick
dabei herzlich willkommen in der Runde
geklick ja vielen vielen Dank ich habe
eine Frage wer was ist der Grund dafür
dass offensichtlich die Behörden so
viele Leute von der Presse vorab
informiert haben
wenn man Waffen sucht und den Leuten
vorher sagt
dass man suchen wird werden wir
versteckt werden und wenn man so viele
Leute vorab informiert muss man davon
ausgehen dass das nicht bei der Presse
bleibt er kriegt das danke Ihnen sehr
für diese Frage weil es etwas was viel
diskutiert würde Frau will ich möchte
gerne mal an Sie weitergeben sie haben
an dem Morgen auch mit berichterstattet
von den Razzien vielleicht können Sie
den Ablauf da noch mal erklären was sie
wussten und warum sie es wussten
vielleicht auch es ist ja natürlich eine
falsche Vorstellung dass man da
irgendwie einen Anruf bekommt dass man
sich irgendwohin begeben möge und
aufstellen weil da jetzt gleich was
stattfindet sondern es finden ja seit
vielen Jahren eigentlich in diesen
Milieus Recherchen statt wir haben
Kollegen die kümmern sich um die
Sicherheitsbehörden wir haben Kollegen
die sich wie ich die AFD anschauen
andere rechtsextreme Milieus bei diesen
Recherchen führen wir mit
unterschiedlichsten Quellen Gespräche
dazu gehören auch immer wieder
Sicherheitsbehörden das sind auch
Quellen und dann erfährt man mal was so
genannt unter eins das hört kann man
dann direkt verwenden oder man fährt er
fährt mal was im Hintergrund meistens
ist aber ein ganz großes langes
langwieriges puzzeln und man nimmt
einzelne Ersatzstücke unterfährt etwas
und man hat dann setzt sich natürlich
auch über so ein Netzwerk ein gewisses
Bild zusammen man hat dann was beisammen
und man bekommt irgendwann dann auch den
Hinweis dass da aber eine
Ermittlungsverfahren läuft dass man
vielleicht nicht gefährden soll und so
kommt es dann dass eben viele Kollegen
sie sich damit beschäftigt haben dann
wussten wann man da das was sie
recherchiert haben veröffentlichen kann
so kann man sich das vorstellen aber
dass da große Listen darüber gereicht
werden weil man sich aufstellen möge wer
da betroffen ist vor und Nachnamen das
ist tatsächlich nicht so sondern ein
Puzzlespiel jeder der beteiligten
Kollegen hat da vielleicht irgendwas
beigetragen und das haben wir auch nicht
alle überall gestanden Herr stark ich
möchte die Frage da gerne noch mit
ergänzen die wir über Twitter bekommen
haben von Markus die Videos der sagt wie
kann es denn sein dass die Medien vorher
informiert waren es gibt ja auch die
Kritik man sei davor den Karren gespannt
worden
welche Bewertung haben sie dazu also bei
uns war es so dass wir vorher Bescheid
wussten aber weil wir
informell von einzelnen Quellen davon
gehört haben alle Versuche von der
Bundesanwaltschaft Information vorab zu
kriegen sind gescheitert das war einfach
so als die Bundesanwaltschaft gehört hat
dass beispielsweise die Zeit aber auch
andere Medien davon trotzdem wissen hat
sie darum gebeten nicht am Mittwoch
Morgen vor 7:30 Uhr zu berichten mit
meinem ganz simplen Argument und das war
die Eigensicherung die der eingesetzten
Beamten ich fand das einen
nachvollziehbaren Grund und habe
deswegen akzeptiert zu sagen dass wir
unsere Berichterstattung bis 37
zurückhalten aber vor dem Mittwochmorgen
sind wir jedenfalls nicht informiert
worden
Alex mager würde ich gerne mit dazu
nehmen aus Marpingen hallo ja
Ihre Frage bitte
ja der Eindruck dass wir hier in einer
scheintdemokratie Leben der ist ja nicht
von der Hand zu weißen aber die Frage
ist was tun die Politiker was tut ARD
und ZDF was tun andere Medien hier mit
dazu dass dieser Eindruck entsteht wenn
man sieht dass Merkels Atlantis Stefan
Herbert Präsident des
Bundesverfassungsgericht ist statt auch
Peter Müller von der CDU sitzt dass in
ARD und zdf-talk Sendungen nur noch
Leute auftreten die einheitsmeinungen
vertreten und solche Professionen wie
beispielsweise haben zwar nach Sinn
nicht mehr eingeladen werden weil sie
konträre Meinung zur
EZB und zwar Europolitik haben das hier
eine Meinungsmache vorsätzlich
durchgeführt wird und da kann man den
Eindruck gewinnen
dürfte dieser Eindruck heute mit
Sicherheit nicht entstanden sein dass
wir immer sehr bemüht sind hier für eine
ausgewogene Berichterstattung das wissen
sie glaube ich auch und wir zeigen es
auch hier im Presseclub an dieser Stelle
an diesem Sonntagvormittag wieder dass
es durchaus kontroverse Diskussionen
hier zu diesem Thema gibt was Herr
Müller könnten sie antworten wurde das
ist richtig das bildet sozusagen die
parteipolitische Stärke ab wenn sie soll
es gibt Verfassungsrechte wurden von den
Grünen nominiert es gibt
verpassungsrichter von der FDP herbert
cdu/csu war früher im Bundestag Peter
Müller war in der Tat Ministerpräsident
Saarlandes aber wenn sie sehen was sich
daraus für eine Rechtsprechung
entwickelt muss man sagen z.B beim Euro
da haben die Regieren in Berlin die
karlsrichter teilweise gehasst weil sie
gesagt haben die machen unsere ganze
Politik kaputt wir wollten eigentlich
ganz anders haben das heißt das auch
kein Beispiel dafür dass alles
gleichgeschaltet wäre und in den Medien
es gibt ja freiwillige Sender die
wiederum auch sehr vielfältig sind
stelle ich jetzt auch keine
Gleichschaltung fest und ehrlich gesagt
Scheindemokratie es ist dem Heinrich dem
Viertel achten umgenommen im Rahmen des
Grundgesetzes eine
volksbewegungsinstizieren und auf eine
Volksabstimmung zur Abschaffung des
Grund Gesetzes uns zur Errichtung einer
Monarchie hinzuwirken kann er machen
muss er Anleihen das steht am
Grundgesetz das Grundgesetz kann durch
eine Volksabstimmung sozusagen aus der
Kraft gesetzt werden also ich sehe die
ganze Bandbreite einer freiheitlichen
Ordnung in unserer Verfassung und die
wird glaube ich auch gelebt und wir
diskutieren noch mit ihnen gerade Herr
mager also insofern ganz ganz so
diktatorisch kann es dann doch nicht
zugehen am Ende und der mag es auch zu
Wort gekommen hier im Presseclub
natürlich mit dieser Meinung Frau wir
haben ja gerade auch über meinungsblasen
gesprochen das ist ja immer gut wenn man
das woanders hin sortiert aber wie wie
nehmen sie das denn immer wenn sie in
der Recherche und in dem wie sie das
dann auch nach außen kommunizieren ja
ich versuche ja regelmäßig mich aus
meiner oder mich eigentlich gar keiner
Blase zuzuordnen das ist eigentlich mein
mein allergrößter meine allergrößte
Vorgabe die ich mir setze weil ich die
Möglichkeit haben möchte mit allen zu
sprechen und wirklich mit allen heißt
mit allen ich kenne übrigens der gerade
im Buch geschrieben hat das heißt
Scheindemokratie und da gehe ich dann
auch trotzdem hin zur Buchvorstellung
und höre mir an obwohl ich keiner dieser
Thesen teile ich würde gerne aus Twitter
Herrn Speyer noch mit dazu nehmen was
kann das Innenministerium zusätzlich
noch tun damit solche Putschversuche in
Zukunft vermieten werden
Herr Müller
das Waffenrecht das angesprochen wurde
das ist ja so ein Symptom könnte man
sagen aber das ist jetzt wie gesagt er
fällt mir nur gerade einen nicht treibt
in der Tat auch manchmal die Frage um
müssen wir so viele legale Waffen haben
es gibt ja Rechtsstaaten die jeden
privaten Waffen Besitz verboten haben
jeglichen Neuseeland England nach
Amokläufen und da stellt sich schon die
Frage weil wir nicht über Staatsdiener
diskutiert das ist eine neue Stufe in
gewisser Weise sondern auch über
bewaffnete Einheiten die auch tot in
Kauf nehmen also insofern finde ich die
Frage bei aller Freiheit die
Sportschützen irgendwie auch lassen will
und Verboten müssen am Ende stehen aber
die Frage warum gibt so viele legale
Waffen es passiert ja auch viel mit
legal erworbenen Waffen Amokläufe von
Schülern Waffe des Vaters aber auch
jetzt wieder
das ist vielleicht schon Punkt der mehr
als nur eine Kleinigkeit ist
bin dem Monika Liste noch mit dazu aus
München hallo Frau Listl ja grüß Gott
ich möchte noch mal zurück zur der
Beteiligung an diesen Umsturz
Überlegungen mir war da zu viel von
ehemaligen bundeswehrlern die rede ich
wollte erinnern dass Frau
Karrenbauer die Sondereinheit der
Bundeswehr vor einiger Zeit aufgelöst
hatte und dann wieder eingesetzt hat und
es war auch vom Verschwinden von Waffen
und Munition damals die Rede
angeblich konnten sich dann die
Bundeswehr die was mitgenommen hatten an
Munition oder Waffen freiwillig melden
und das zurückgeben aber das ist doch
eine Sache die ist doch nie richtig
aufgeklärt worden oder zumindestens
haben wir in der Öffentlichkeit davon
nichts erfahren wie das dann aufgeklärt
wurde
naja es gab ein Gerichtsverfahren von
einem kskala der Waffen und Munition bei
sich zu Hause im Garten vergraben hatte
der ist dafür auch verurteilt worden und
dann ist die Kompanie in der diese
Vorfälle im Wesentlichen stattgefunden
haben tatsächlich aufgelöst worden und
dann restrukturiert worden es ist auch
der Kommandeur des KSK ausgetauscht
worden ich glaube da sind schon ein paar
Sachen geschehen die richtig sind und
ähm trotzdem lernen wir jetzt natürlich
dass es immer wieder so kleinere Biotope
gibt das ist glaube ich was was man
nicht mit dem Schalter umlegen kann
sondern was einen langer Prozess ist was
lange dauert und wo noch viel Wegstrecke
vor uns liegt sie wollten ergänzen ja
also man muss ja auch sagen dass auch
damals in diesem Fall ist so war dass
ähm konkrete Pläne also jetzt beim Fall
Nordkreuz beispielsweise konkrete Pläne
gehabt wen man abzuholen hatte in
Anführungsstrichen na also wer beseitigt
werden sollte im Zuge der Recherche ist
auch klar geworden dass es so weit ging
dass man sich beispielsweise Grundrisse
einer Wohnung
von einem potenziellen politischen Feind
dann besorgt hat das heißt es muss schon
sagen das waren sehr konkrete
Vorstellungen teilweise bis hin dass man
sich Schießübungen getroffen hat und da
würde ich mir auch wünschen dass
deutlich schneller und doch schon
konsequenter agiert wird weil wenn man
in bestimmten Umfeldern der Bundeswehr
mehrfachfälle hat wo so etwas Auftritt
da muss man doch erkennen dass da ein
strukturelles Problem da ist und dadurch
tatsächlich auch die Auffassung der
Anruferin teilen dass man hier in
Zukunft auch genauer hinschauen
wie stark schon gesagt hat
weil wir gar nicht mehr so viel Zeit
haben nehmen Benjamin Piano gerne aus
Wildberg noch mit dazu holen
meine Frage ist ob diese also es sind ja
diverse Leute in diesen in diesen
rechten Gruppen jetzt oder in diesen
verschwörungstheoretikergruppen
identifiziert worden meiner Meinung nach
aus der Mitte der Gesellschaft kommen
also Ärzte Rechtsanwälte Richter und so
weiter kann ja nicht davon ausgehen dass
das dumme Leute sind sondern die haben
ja auch eine gewisse Reputation und
verfangen dann trotzdem diese diesen
Ideologien und meine Frage war woher
kommt das ich kann dann nur zu dem
Schluss kommen dass es keine rational
folgerichtlichen Argumentationen sind
die die dahin führen sondern das ist
eher ein emotionales Thema ist und in
der Sendung wird ja auch gesagt dass
diese die AFD anfangs Euro kritisch war
und sich dann immer weiter in so eine
rechte Partei entwickelt hat ich
erinnere mich aber damals als der Bernd
Socke diese Partei gegründet haben ich
muss sie ganz kurz unterbrechen weil
sonst haben wir keine Zeit mehr für eine
schnelle Antwort noch die Sekunden
laufen weg danke schön für Ihre Frage
Frau will schnell antworten noch ich
weiß gar nicht eine Frage warum ehrlich
zu sein also es gibt Studien die haben
sich angeschaut gibt es einen
Zusammenhang zwischen Bildung und
Intelligenz und Neigung zu
verschwörungsglauben und die Antwort ist
nicht wirklich also man sieht eine
leichte Tendenz schon beim
Bildungsabschluss aber man muss sagen
das lässt sich eher auch durch andere
Faktoren erklären insgesamt muss man
sagen das ging schon immer quer durch
die Bevölkerung und von da sollte es
einen auch nicht überraschen das auch
beispielsweise bei Querdenken auch hin
und wieder Professoren auf der Bühne
stand ich möchte an der Stelle sagen
Danke schön für Ihre Fragen für ihr
mitdiskutieren beim Presseclub heute
Danke schön an die Runde für die
Antworten dazu schön dass sie mit
Interesse dabei waren das war der
Presseclub einen schönen Sonntag noch
[Musik]